bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
numéro spécial sur l'idée ce festival
qui a déjà attiré plus de deux millions
et demi de personnes depuis sa création
l'année dernière c'était 180 mille
personnes qui se sont vendus ici avec un
seul mot d'ordre solidarité
cette année ce sont 80 concerts qui sont
programmés pour la lutte contre le sida
alors suivez-moi on va faire un tour
solidays aujourd'hui est une vitrine du
militantisme et des revendications
notamment en ce qui concerne les
financements l'international donc voilà
la france doit annoncer sa contribution
au fonds mondial sida tuberculose pas
lui et voilà on sait que solidays bien
évidemment dans sa capacité à mobiliser
a rassemblé joue un rôle aujourd'hui
moteur notamment vis-à-vis de l'état
français le succès de solidays aide
aussi à faire valoir les enjeux du sida
l'international c'est une évidence il
silva
oui
c'est un
alors solide et c'est un festival qui
n'existerait pas non plus sans l'aide de
la région
la présidente valérie pécresse est venue
faire un petit tour de piste comme le
faisait son prédécesseur jean paul
huchon c'est un engagement qu'on a voulu
absolument maintenir parce que solide et
c'est pas seulement un grand événement
culturel régional
mais c'est aussi un grand événement sur
la prévention santé et que l'engagement
sur toute la prévention sylla et sur
tout et qu'on dit à risque est vraiment
absolument fondamental pour nous folie
de france dernière question sur qu'elle
sonne on va vous retrouver là il est
pour l'instant sur la scène régionale
bienvenue
même cerizéen n'existerait pas sans les
bénévoles de solidarité sida
ils sont près de 1500 cette année à
faire tourner la machine partout il y en
a même qui pose 38 de vacances pour
faire le montage est davantage ce
festival c'est le leur soyons clairs -
ce qui de nos vies c'est de les voir se
dépasser se défoncer voilà aller puiser
dans leurs réserves dans leur physique
pour donner meilleure et je crois
capable belle récompense pour le
fondateur que je suis de voir toute
cette jeunesse qui a toujours envie
donner davantage pour se rendre utile
les bénévoles les voilà je suis avec
reza qui est bénévole depuis six ans sur
solide est déjà résa pourquoi tu as
décidé d'être bénévole sur le festival
alors moi la base
je suis j'ai connu de solides et en tant
que festivaliers et en voyant tous ces
tee shirt blanc je vous dis qu'est ce
qui se cache derrière tout ça ils ont
l'air vraiment sympa
alors du coup je ne dis pas tiens je
vais m'inscrire je vais voir comment ça
fonctionne et les gens étaient vraiment
sympa donc je me dis demain derrière ça
peut être vraiment cool et ça m'a
tellement plu que aujourd'hui je reste
en tant que bénévole et plus jamais je
reviendrai festivaliers pour moi c'est
une famille donc je me plaît tellement
que voilà j'y reste
c'est l'ambiance mais aussi le message
du festival tout à fait venir ici alors
d'abord le message qui était vraiment
axé sur quelque chose de très humain au
niveau de la communication c'était assez
humain aussi c'étaient des choses qui
étaient très touchante c'est quelque
chose qui me parlait énormément et c'est
ce qui a fait que j'ai choisi ce
festival plutôt que d'autres
si soit super feeling dès maintenant
solidays summer of love en 2016 c'est
cette scène mais aussi beaucoup d espace
dansant et musicaux ici une des deux
plus grandes scènes leur célibat la
radio on écoute une belle bande de bras
cassés mais au moins on serre les coudes
on est bien content de refaire
s'épuisant comme d'art sa femme débarque
sur michael jackson
nous sommes ici au village solidarité
est plutôt le village des associations
elles sont plus d'une centaine à être
venus du monde entier
ici c'est l'occasion pour les
festivaliers de venir chercher des
informations sur le vih mais aussi
beaucoup d'autres thèmes comme la santé
le droit humain ou encore le
développement durable c'est ici que ça
se passe
les questions qui sont causés sont un
peu toujours les mêmes par exemple il ya
des confusions entre vih et sida donc je
leur ai expliqué que veillard passé le
virus du sida c'est un stade de la
maladie due au virus
et puis toujours savoir si on en meurt
s'il ya quelque chose qui est des
médicaments qui soirée face aux kings
fait des questions basiques parce que
malheureusement les jeunes
encore ignorants sur sur le vih
aujourd'hui nous demandons de garder le
silence pendant cet instant
c'est une tradition à solidays tous les
ans on énumère le nom des personnes qui
sont mortes du sida
madame agnès patrie s'appelle phrase qui
disait l'amour la seule chose qui double
à chaque fois qu'on le donne vous parle
souvent dire avoir un coeur sur la main
ici à solidaires ils ont à coeur sur
chaque main et c'est ça dont on a besoin
notre époque la bienveillance c'est un
cercle vertueux spirale vertueuse plus
on est bienveillant plutôt monde est
heureux plus en été on reçoit même dont
les gagnants
solidays pour moi c'est quoi bas c'est
la lutte contre le sida c'est un
festival
c'était tout le monde soit solidaire
autour de la musique de la culture et de
l'événement la solidarité contre le sida
une façon de lutter de chansons qu'on
décidera tout en s'amusant c'est trop
bien les festivals comme ça parce que ça
réunit la musique et donc le plaisir
avec aussi du des luttes contre les
causes pour lesquelles il faut qu'on se
bat tous les jours alors c'est trop bien
à chaque fois qu'on lance une opération
strictement généreuse on est toujours
dépassé par les conséquences et par
conséquent je suis très fier de
participer à la solidarité sida pour
maintes raisons en plus de la cause
parce que les gens qui travaillent à
l'accomplissement de ce projet ce sont
des gens puisque puisque merveilleux
vraiment et c'est celle écoute c'est les
côtoyer qui donne envie d'aller de
l'avant puisque la maladie même c'est
c'est ça qui est sublime c'est que
devant la noirceur d'une cause qu'on
défend et la lumière des gens qui se
battent contre cette maladie souvent en
avance ou le temps main pour mon pote si
tu peux être à l'heure où tu t'étais les
portes
quand on frappe il n'y a pas de
prochainement la vie est courte et la
mort à tout
ici on est dans l'espace média c'est ici
que les journalistes viennent se reposer
mais aussi rencontrer des artistes et
avec un peu de chance on peut rencontrer
de grosses têtes d'affiché comme ibrahim
maalouf qui est juste derrière mans et à
quelques engagements qui sont qui sont
indispensables même encore aujourd'hui
évidemment trouver des remèdes pour pour
aider les
les gens qui ont le sida les
séropositifs trouver des solutions pour
que la vie soit un truc un peu moins
compliqué la cause des réfugiés moi-même
parle beaucoup aussi
y'a pas l'art ya plein de situations
comme ça qu'ils qui nécessite que qu'on
s'engage tous
je pense que c'est c'est très très
chouette que ce festival est pris non le
cette dimension là celui qui tourne la
migraine quand tu t'interroges les rêves
s'éloigne qui courent à leur poursuite
en vieillissant vie de moins en moins
l'oubli poursuivre je fais une
exposition qui s'appelle ayem oued zem
qui est en ce moment à l'institut du
monde arabe et qui est aussi dans les
solidays c'est un manifeste
photographique qui a une double ambition
qui est d'abord que nous les regardions
non plus comme une masse faire un par un
car un parent ça fait des milliers à la
fin mais ils sont 1 + 1 et quand leur
rendant leur humanité on retrouve un peu
de la nôtre aussi
c'est 180 mille jeunes qui vont regarder
ezzeldine couchera et l'âme et naouar
que c'est important qu'on dise aux
réfugiés
nous savons que vous êtes là et vous
êtes parmi nous vous êtes déjà parmi
nous et nous devons vous regardez et
vous accueillir parmi nous
les festivals c'est pas forcément que du
bonheur entre les concerts on va boire
une petite bière ou un peu d'eau et on a
forcément envie d'aller aux toilettes et
ça c'est là que
ici à solidays la solidarité c'est aussi
avec les bleus et comme l'euro de
football se déroule pendant le festival
les organisateurs ont même prévu leur
propre fan zone en installant des écrans
géants pour retransmettre le match
ça y est le festival touche à sa fin le
chiffre de 200 mille personnes a été
atteint mais le compteur risque de
monter encore un petit peu parce que la
journée n'est pas terminée
en tout cas merci à tous les
festivaliers d'être venu mais surtout à
vous pour vous avoir regardé
à